your grades were almost
derailed by a mutant algorithm
sounds terrifying although it's a bit
less scary when you see it
like this the methodology published by
exam regulator ofqual
about its discredited marking system is
a chunky
318 pages and although produce some
freaky results
it's really just statistics
although when the royal statistical
society offered off qual
expert help the regulator refused
unless the experts signed a five-year
non-disclosure agreement
it's a very broad non-disclosure
agreement was this a mutant algorithm
newton algorithm is a really colorful
way of describing it some of the results
from it
may not have been predicted by people
within government but on the other hand
some of these things were entirely
predictable the fact that it would
prioritize reducing grade inflation
even at the expense of some individuals
getting results they didn't deserve
that was predictable this wasn't a
mutant or a freak of nature this was
something that could have been foreseen
we asked downing street for a response
they declined to comment
victoria who is predicted aaa by her
school
then given bbc by the algorithm
feels let down by the government boris
johnson he's in charge of the government
he was in charge of the people who are
creating it if it's a mutant we we
knew it was going to be created this way
for months in advance
so why didn't he stop it why don't you
say hey this is wrong like we need to do
it differently
the thing about algorithms is that once
you start looking for them
they're everywhere not just on this
thing but changing the traffic lights or
deciding the bus timetable
look there's a bank did you know that
algorithms decide
who gets loans they're carrying mutants
but most of the time
they're simple yet powerful and
increasingly they're being used in
our public services when we investigated
the use of predictive algorithms and
public services last year
we found them in 53 local authorities
and 14 police forces to some
that's progress to others it's a worry
this is just one example of one
algorithm that we all know about
but where else is it being used does it
have a
similar level of transparency are there
similar issues that's affecting this
exam's algorithm
affecting other parts of public services
we need
a tool to alert us about algorithms
a perfect job for an algorithm
sky news